[Musique]
11h20 gare de volgelsheim pas de trains
prévus aujourd'hui ni demain ni même
dans les jours qui suivent
pourtant les rails sont bien là mais
depuis 1969
le trafic voyageur est interrompue sur
la partie française de la ligne
historique du colmar strasbourg
impossible également au train de passer
le rhin à ce niveau détruits en février
1945 le pont ferroviaire n'a jamais été
reconstruit un oubli de l'après-guerre
qui laisse la capitale haut rhinoise
sans connexion rapide avec sa voisine
allemande
je me suis toujours posé la question
pourquoi cette liaison n'existait pas
alors que du côté allemand entre
fribourg et browser donc la dernière
commune avant la frontière
il y à un train qui circule tous les
jours pas que une fois deux fois mais
d'entre 5 heures du matin et minuit avec
et quatorze mille passagers par jour
et pourquoi ils continuent pas jusqu'à
colmar
l'association transrail milite pour la
réouverture d'une liaison ferroviaire
entre colmar et fribourg une desserte
régulière entre les deux villes
présenterait de nombreux atouts pour le
territoire et ne sait ce que ce soit
touristique donc pour les allemands qui
souhaitent rejoindre la france colmar où
les vosges
inversement pareil les français qui
pourraient rejoindre l'allemagne la
forêt noire fribourg
mais c'est sûr aussi économique nous
avons beaucoup de personnes qui
traversent la frontière quotidiennement
et ce serait justement un super atout
pour eux de prendre le train car nous
avons cas il faut quand même une heure
et demie entre colmar et fribourg en
voiture alors qu'il en faudrait
seulement 45 minutes en train l'autre à
tous et on parle beaucoup de chômage
chez les jeunes
pourquoi parce qu'ils trouvent pas
d'emploi en france parce qu'ils n'ont
pas forcément le permis de conduire et
ça leur permettrait quand même de
rejoindre leur lieu de travail sans
vraiment être dépendant d'une voiture ou
d'un autre moyen de locomotion
côté allemand un train toutes les
demi-heures connect freibourg à brizard
et assurent le transport quotidien de
nombreux travailleurs de la région pour
l'heure rien d'équivalent côté français
mais la réouverture de la ligne
transfrontalière pourrait bien doper le
trafic donc pour les connexions entre la
france et l'allemagne que pour la
desserte locale
en 2004 il ya une première étude qui a
été réalisée qui chiffrait environ 700
passagers par jour
la nouvelle étude elle arrive sur un
chiffre entre 5 à 6000 vols passagers
par jour entre colmar et
et fall cas ça y est c'est quand même
pour nous un super une super nouvelle
parce que ça montre aussi qu'il ya un
intérêt de la population
le projet de ligne colmar fribourg a
connu une forte accélération ces
dernières années explique dans le traité
d' axa chapelle en 2019 il fait
également partie du projet de territoire
de fessenheim il est pour ainsi dire
lancé sur ses rails aujourd'hui nous
venons de signer très exactement le 30
juin
les études pré opérationnelles pour les
sept lignes ferroviaires ça veut dire
que ces études pré opérationnelles vont
aboutir d'ici fin 2022 à une enquête
publique et donc ensuite le démarrage
des travaux
l'objectif j'ai envie de dire de
l'inauguration de la mise en service de
cette ligne c'est 2027
c'est en un objectif ambitieux mais qui
est tout à fait réaliste et est tout à
fait tenable
les allemands vient de terminer
l'électrification de la ligne entre
brizard et fribourg l'essentiel des
travaux devrait donc se dérouler sur la
partie française est au dessus du rhin
en france c'est surtout qu entre
fegersheim donc lagarde ici et colmar
nous avons une voix qui est quand même
dans un
un état critique et qui devrait être
refaite
actuellement on peut circuler à 40 km
heure ce n'est pas le but le il faudrait
quand même pouvoir circuler entre 80 et
100 km heure comme nous l'avons du côté
allemand donc du coup il faudrait
refaire la ligne et surtout entre
volgelsheim la gare et au hasard il
faudrait créer une nouvelle ligne où
l'ancien refaire l'ancienne ligne de
1945 et qu'on se trouve trois ponts
d'affilée si des études techniques vont
être lancés dans les prochaines semaines
des analyses prospectives avaient déjà
été réalisées par les partenaires
franco-allemand pour établir une
estimation des coûts
les premières études nous ont démontré
qu'en fonction des options qui seront
retenues ou pas ça sera un budget qui
aussi entre 235 et 275 millions d'euros
alors c'est certain budget important
mais c'est un budget qui est partagé
entre des partenaires français et des
partenaires allemands et surtout aussi
c'est un projet qui est inscrit au
traité d'aix la chapelle et qui va
pouvoir bénéficier de fonds européens
importants
c'est une opportunité juste
extraordinaire et je pense qu'il faut
pas la louper
l'étude technique à elle seule est
budgétée à plus de 3 millions d'euros et
va durer deux ans avant d'aboutir au
lancement d'une enquête publique un coût
déjà partagée entre français et
allemands il y a une volonté
côté allemand du land de bade-würtemberg
mais aussi du boult de berlin qui
cofinance tous les deux cette étude pré
opérationnelle et côté français c'est
l'état français
la région et le département du haut rhin
qui participent il faut dire aussi qu
aujourd'hui il faut et c'est vraiment
lors de mes chevaux de bataille il faut
de plus en plus raisonner en transports
en commun en transport décarbonés et ça
sera le cas de ce train donc c'est c'est
plus que jamais à l'ordre du jour
aujourd'hui ouverte de la ligne prévue
entre 2026 et 2030
le conseil départemental du haut-rhin
table sur 8
des 2027